one of the beautiful sights of last
year's show was Jane Wyman and a white
crepe evening dress accepting an Academy
Award well you can give odds one of the
beautiful sights of this year's show
will be Jane Wyman in a white lace
evening dress presenting an Academy
Award in fact this girl's in a rut she's
stuck with good looks good humor good
grace and two white dresses to present
the Oscar for the Best Performance by an
actor Miss Jane Wyman
before the winner is announced I at this
time would like to congratulate him
because after his name is read he won't
remember it he won't remember anything
for 24 hours
so those nominated for the best
performance by an actor are Broderick
Crawford in all the king's men a Robert
Ross and production Columbia Kirk
Douglas in the champion screenplays
corporation United Artists Gregory Peck
twelve O'Clock High 20th Century Fox
Richard Todd in the hasty heart Warner
Brothers and John Wayne in sands of Iwo
Jima Republic the envelope please
Rick Crawford
such a long time
great theme
here is very very happy
looks divine in a white dress if my
heart would stop beating for a malicious
mr. Douglas said I was to thank nobody
I'd like to thank all of you and
especially thank God
congratulations to you broad broad
Crawford ah
that's exciting